I've ranked four thousand six hundred
some movies I've given 23 films five
stars I expected this to be like between
a four four and a half this is a four
and a half approaching a five I don't
give a five star until the second
viewing this is this isn't my top
hundred movies of all time it's
approaching right yeah I adore this film
hello hello hello everybody and welcome
to another episode of the after show but
I shouldn't call it just another episode
of the after show because this is our
first double feature episode of the
after show and yes I am talking about
the worldwide phenomenon known as barbin
Heimer and
our very special guest there's nobody
else that could Barber Heimer this
episode like you and I know that for a
fact and I knew you'd Barbie so I had to
offer I love that I was like okay who am
I doing the show with I'm doing it with
Barbara yourself so let's open it up and
I'm very excited about it I'm glad that
everybody's finally try starting to
catch up on the barbie thing because
I've been barbieing for 10 years uh
morning come on you've been Barbie for
you've been a Barbie of the people for
quite some time we've I've talked about
this on my social media but
in Tarantino I showed up at the Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood Premiere in
pink okay I also think that we're now
seeing Barbie as the icon she is in a
positive and I think that's one of the
people think about the movie is that we
we see what a Barbie is and I think a
new generation is about to find out what
a Barbie is and that's interesting
because oppenheimer's the same thing I
think these are two mythical figures one
fiction one non-fiction that represents
so much more so for them to be one thing
as barberheimer is amazing an analysis
of mid-century America there's my
intellect for the day no it's
mid-century America it's capitalism it's
voyeurism it's a commentary on like what
Cinema is to people it's a commentary on
what meta mononymous metamodernism is
today to box office and I think we'll
look back on this in the same way that
Barbie looked back in The Godfather like
there's a lot of like self-reflection
mirroring in both these movies there's
like Fight Club references in Barbie
there's Godfather references yeah it's
Gathering a lot of masculinity but I
think that this is going to be the
feminine energy that the masculinity of
Godfather and Fight Club are in movie
for future filmmakers 20 years from now
so everybody else can go back rewind
that and then slow motion it and watch
it again and because it went
and it's a lot of those really
oppenheimer's a hyper masculine film
versus this beautiful feminine film
there's there's we were
gonna unpack for 10 years we're gonna
unpack a lot today but yes we are going
to be unpacking this for a very long
time
um by the way this is a spoiler-filled
episode so if you haven't barberheimered
you should barberheimer and then come
back and watch
um okay so let's first talk about the
fact that uh the box office was boffo
yes
um 162 million for Barbie 82.4 for
Oppenheimer for a cool 244 million
dollars and then in its totality
including Mission Impossible other films
that open that were out in theaters the
fourth biggest weekend of all time in
North America behind you know Infinity
war end game and then the force awakens
my boys it's like crazy but I love the
fact that these are two original films
yeah and one of them is yes an IP but
it's still the first of a franchise
which I hope has 10 installments like
Avengers like I hope we get to the point
where there's like 25 of these but I
don't think people are giving it the
credit that it's the first time this has
happened with two firsts yeah like this
is an Avengers end game that movie had
so much lead up so much build up like
right you had to have 23 movies set up
in game to have that kind of box office
this is the number two non-holiday box
office Monday of all time today's box
office or yesterday's is the number
number two ever that wasn't on holiday
for Barbie were you as giddy as I was
all weekend I swear our producer said
how was your weekend and I was like I
don't think I did anything but kept
refreshing my computer to look at the
box office I went to Comic-Con every
time you actually had something to do so
in between every panel I was checking
the box office like was the stock market
so it was so funny I was like really
busy I was like how's it going and it
was so beautiful to just see the joy of
it because it was all a celebration it
wasn't a winner or loser it was we were
all at the movies and I love that like
the next spot was Tom Cruise who's Mr
movies like I love that everything was
just revelry and it was it was joyful in
the sense of we obviously love movies
and we're movie fans but I had more
calls from people who don't necessarily
go to the movies and are like I'm gonna
barvinheimer which one should I do first
or I went and saw barbie and I left and
this is what excites me even more is
that because of this phenomenon you had
people from two different maybe who
wouldn't necessarily have seen the other
and when we you know I went to advance I
went to a press screening so I'm always
a little nervous like are the P are the
Barbie fans who are like 20 going to see
Oppenheimer not I'm not judging anybody
but for the most part that was the
consensus is that some of these people
who are 20 and going with their friends
they're gonna go see Oppenheimer are
they gonna like it right and they did
that's what's so beautiful is it's going
to open up a whole new we're going to
look back at this box office not just
because the numbers but because it's
going to expose a lot of people to
different genres to different styles of
filmmaking to different actors like it's
actually pretty shocking that there
weren't any crossover actors considering
the scope of these casts but like it's
really interesting to be like I'm gonna
go from Barbie who is like you know Ryan
Gosling Margot Robbie to like who's that
incredible character actor like what's
this Nolan guy and they probably known
from the Dark Knight and stuff but they
might have like made Nolan fans out of
people that bourbonheimered and Greta
gerwig's definitely gonna have some
people that like should they're gonna
discover her older work which is more
independent in nature than what no one's
been doing lately so I think honestly
this wasn't just a celebration of these
two movies it was truly a celebration of
Cinema because people calling you to ask
which one to see first means they're
invested even in the order of the
experience of Barber timer now I
actually did the barberheimer did you
you get to I I because it was press
screening so okay I actually
did the Barbie Haunted Mansion because I
did Barbie and then Haunted Mansion that
night okay and then Oppenheimer I did
the next day so within 24 hours within
24 hours okay but you barvin tell me
about your experience I saw a 12 15
Barbie okay and I had a three o'clock
operation
it's called barberheimer not open beat
like it is it is the right method
because honestly I think you can do it
however you want because you're
supporting Cinema so I appreciate you
but I think the oppressive Doom that you
walk away with from Oppenheimer
shouldn't go into bars you were asking
me and I and a lot of you I think the
conventional wisdom originally was the
Oppenheimer first and then end on a high
note and I was like no you don't want to
go into Barbie with Oppenheimer energy
the other way around yeah because I I
definitely also I went and got in and
out between because I was like 50s
bopping like I was I was feeling like
this
it definitely felt right I walked into
the I went to the Americana I went to
the nice bigger in and out and I just
looked around like yeah Barbie energy I
think I had the kennergy that I brought
by the way as you're talking I think you
should be in the sequel I think if
there's it can spin-off need it you need
the energy that I bring with Beyond a
lot of energy there's no version I'm not
Ken for Halloween which I know everyone
will be that's going to be this year's
like Jack Sparrow but I accept that I'll
be the better kid uh and I'm gonna
Barbie but I have a I've picked out a
Barbie that no one's done yet that I
haven't seen oh that's amazing yeah so
like the the way that I did it I think
is a a really wonderful Journey because
the high of Barbie you go in with more
energy to go into Oppenheimer which I
think is neat it's a three-hour film and
it's a very big experience of a film but
I also felt that the end of my six hour
Journey that last hour of Oppenheimer is
so aggressive and so intense so I felt
the cumulative nature of barberheimer in
a way that felt like a hydrogen bomb
because I'd been at the movies for six
hours so like the five hour markets
building that Crescendo of the crazy
courtroom and everything and I was just
like I've lived Cinema and it felt so
much that I had I could have written a
thesis paper on Barbie when it was done
but went off and I was done I sat in
silenced during the credits and just
felt the weight of the experience a lot
of it a lot of people have said said
that you do sit there through the
credits and I actually sat through the
credits of Barbie because weirdly and
let's start getting into our review of
Barbie first I'll just mention
um this is what I love about both of
these films too they they twinned with
this Tomato Meter scores with the
audience score and the critics score
yeah so Barbie had a 90 critic score and
then a 90 audience score and then we'll
get to it a little bit later but
Oppenheimer had a 94-94 I'm like you two
are just so cute you guys are made for
each other never break up never they're
all right their their lives are forever
entwined even if they get divorced
they're sharing custody oh my gosh okay
so the critics consensus oh so I should
mention also the records that Barbie did
break because it made 162 million like I
said at the domestic box office the best
opening of 2023 beating Super Mario
Brothers movie which I'm
shocked I Love You Mario but thank you
Barbie exactly the biggest opening by a
female director
um Anna Bowden was co-director of
Captain Marvel as you know and Patty
Jenkins Wonder Woman were both beat
um and yeah combined total fourth 244.4
fourth highest box office in history
um so yeah so just overall your thoughts
on Barbie overall thoughts on Barbie oh
wow
um okay Barbie I think is one of the
better New Uses and if you guys follow
me or know my work you know I love this
study of art but meta modernism is what
I think we are succeeding at as a
culture right now okay explain what that
is so metamodernism is like sincere
irony simultaneously with ironic
sincerity so it's the idea that you're
smiling and crying at the same time that
there's a wink to the knowledge that
it's something that is self-aware of
itself but not in a way that's
patronizing so the Lego movie is a great
example of meta modernism Deadpool as a
character is a great example of
metamodernism uh everything that Donald
Glover has done as Charles Gambino from
late Camp through because the internet
and slightly into his new era of Redbone
that that feel of knowing you're in
something while the audience is with you
and I think the internet's a large part
of that the internet is basically the
audience but it's incorporated into the
thing you're making marketing has become
metamodernistic the way that we're using
memes as part of the culture cocaine
bear is metamodernistic so this lens of
which we're watching things that are
educational but knowing that it's like
we're gonna make a very very sincere
Barbie movie but also the dialogue is
going to make it known that it's funny
but also these actors are in it in a way
that is sincerely ironic the entire
performance that Margo and Ken do 100
even call him Ryan I said Ken that's how
much he was Ken but what they put in
there was this self-awareness that is
also sincere to the story and a lot of
times these multiversal movies the way
this goes from the world of Barbie land
into our world that's the definition of
it because it's meta in that it's
overlooking something but it's modern in
a way that's sincere not like
um the 90s when it'd be like oh they're
they're trapped in this world like like
um Who Framed Roger rabbits not meta
modernistics more of a commentary and
Oppenheimer is more of a little bit more
of a commentary because it's talking
about the birth of the h-bomb and the
A-bomb but that's also at the end kind
of like well we're leading towards AI
there's more of a commentary there so
Barbie for me was one of the better
examples of how to do it in a very very
saccharine bright and an incredibly like
stimulating digestible way but still
digestible in a way that is teaching
lessons that I was so impressed at the
fact that Barbie is a 50s icon she's
classic Americana she's all these things
and all they needed to do was one simple
flip of a switch where you made the
supporting character what would have
been a female character in this era
filmmaking a male character and instead
of making it all female energy it's male
kennergy that is simply the masculine
tropes of our and that time and you
flipped it so he's not a weak character
he's not a dumb character he's not an
anything character he's a character that
would have been supporting so the Barbie
world is a matriarchy and our world is a
patriarchy and it's not even a
commentary in a way that's judging
either it's acknowledging either and
thank you and it's just getting it and
of course you do but thank you for
pointing it out in such a simple way
because that is exactly what it is so
anybody who says it's male bashing it's
not it's it's look at any movie Hell
look at movies today I'm not even gonna
say from before look at how so many men
treat women today they take away their
autonomy they take away the way they're
uh
they take away everything that makes a
person a person to serve them in a way
that is so inhuman and then they think
that anyone that stands up to just being
a level of human is
feminism in a swear word way feminism is
equality and this movie isn't about a
feminism that is bashing men or a
feminism that is putting one below the
other it is saying like hey imagine a
world where we're actually equal and
that transition of power has to happen
in a way that feels jarring it's a
pendulum swing I think a big problem
with Society right now is we're fighting
towards equality and the Pendulum has to
swing a little higher and sometimes it
feels like oppression and a little lower
but oppression only feels like
oppression when you've been someone
below someone else like equality is
going to feel like oppression to the
majority so I thought the movie handled
beautifully Ken being a woman from the
50s time play it as a male with male
energy that just showed how imbalanced
things are and it's a beautiful Fable of
what things should and could be and some
of my favorite elements since we're in
spoilers is him like the patriarchy that
doesn't involve horses as much as I hope
like there were elements of just pure
humor to make us go like okay you're not
trying to grandstand me you're not
trying to beat this over my head this is
just not a world that's acceptable and I
thought it handled all that really well
thought the comedy was genius I thought
the use of Alan was really clever
because it gave us an eye line in on the
joke because I feel he played it almost
so sincerely 100 like I feel like Alan
was a great example of in the world of
Ken's when you're Alan you're just
trying to find your place in the world
so his his Arc was genius because he
found his place amongst the Barbies
because he didn't have other Ken's he
didn't know where he belonged he didn't
he to me he was almost uh like an to use
like the sexual Spectrum he was like an
asexual character in a world of of you
know either hetero homosexuals where
he's like I'm the one of one where do I
fit in in these two camps and like what
do I do and then he found his Happiness
by like accepting himself as Alan but
all of Ken's close Fitness I know it's
so interesting I've I've had so many
males reach out to me since seeing
Barbie who will say I'm I'm Alan
a lot of guys like you know I would
figure a lot of guys would be like well
of course I'm Ken I'm sure the star of
the show kind of thing but he there a
lot of guys I'm reaching out going on
now and the message at the end where
like Barbie can be a mom Barbie can be a
mom that's a president Mommy give me
anyone I think that's a really important
message for people that think that one
for for men or women that feel like they
have to be president and two men think
that women that are stay-at-home moms
are any lesser than a mom that is
President a mom that is running a
company a mom that is CEO that's a
full-time job that's awesome like that
is that is a powerful position in our
society and I love that Barbie not only
had to go through her Walkabout journey
and I love robots becoming autonomous
Journey like the Sci-Fi of the 70s and I
love that this film had Barbie become
self-aware in a human way while
referencing 70s tropes and it had the
male figure become self-aware in a way
that referenced 70 strokes but also our
modern like he dressed like Tyler Durden
like the modern masculinity tropes but
they both had their own Heroes journeys
of self-autonomy while Alan got to find
his way while audiences get to find out
who identify with and then while
everyone gets to realize like oh these
ideas that I've been treating people
with are not fair because they have
their own journey to go on and it made a
quarter billion dollars I literally feel
warm after you just
to say and this is what I was going to
say before uh we started talking about
Barbie was that um the way you said you
sat in Oppenheimer and didn't leave
that's how I sat in Barbie wonderful and
the moment that made me I spontaneously
burst into tears and I didn't understand
why was just the Montage of all the
girls at the very end that they show
yeah just hit me in such a way and it
was such um I thought of my mom I just
thought of my mom being a mom yeah mom
was a teacher who then decided to be a
stay-at-home mom and raise my brother
and I but it it was just like it was
such
because no matter your relationship to
Barbie because I did not have a
complicated relationship with Barbie
growing up it was all love I had no
problem with Barbie growing up ever and
so but that's the message of the movie
that no matter what your relationship
with Barbie is
and that was what the Montage
encapsulated is all types of different
and I sat there and I cried and the
second I walked out I saw a rep from
Warner Brothers and she was like so
what'd you think I was the only person
in Pink by the way because it was all
critics and apparently before I came in
you know they had to budge you in it was
at a place where you had to be let in
and one of the
people there were like there's a girl
here all in pink do you think she's
trying to crash the screening and
somebody from Warner Brothers is like no
that's Nikki Novak we already know no
photo required we go ahead and let her
in we know who that is so I was the girl
that I am the Barbie Barbie girl like
I've been dressing in pink for years I
was the girl that went into this movie
and my favorite part of the movie was
the first 30 minutes because that was
the world and like let's just give
production design the Oscar now because
if you look behind the scenes about how
they shot it because it is so surreal
the world yeah and it was obviously shot
on a stage but looks like a real world
it is
it is extraordinary I almost wish they
went even further with that like when
she was with the waffle and the cream
and the coffee because one thing you do
as a kid when you play with Barbies
whether or not you had a Barbie house I
had a Barbie house that was you know a
lot of the walls are flat yeah and
stuff's just sort of drawn in so like
the cupboards but you will have a cup
and you will have this I would have even
gone further with that yeah
depth of field and all that I wanted to
even and I know Margo's one request was
when she talked to Greta about writing
the script because Margo produced it and
approached grandma
she said I just want to slide from the
bedroom down to the pool and that was
the Holy Cross moment I love that she
walked onto the pool I love that they
didn't like like immediately know the
world because she slides down and then
steps under the pool and walks away and
you're like that's Barbie yes yes and
then there was like when she jumps off
and that was the whole thing when when
you take a Barbie from the top floor
down to and how she jumps off and that
was like an unwash to Marilyn Monroe
yeah and then in the background somebody
pointed out there was a Jackie O oh I
didn't know what a thing and early on I
think it was like I want to say it was
in the 80s somebody made a point I don't
remember who it was are you a Jackie or
are you a Marilyn and it was almost like
an insult having to choose between the
two and and that was Greta's that was an
intention I want to watch this with the
Marvel lens of give me your Easter eggs
give me your references yeah no it's
coming next no less I wanted one
enjoyment run now I'm gonna dive in
really frame by frame Tarantino picture
of him outside in Westwood yes in the
very spot where Margot Robbie shot her
scene from Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
he was wearing a bar behind your T-shirt
I would have lost it that would have
been the best that would have been as
good as this Tom buying the tickets like
that would have been the same level of
marketing of like this is how it's done
yes
um
anything else that you were sort of your
favorite parts or any criticisms that
you have for the film
um honestly I I so I went in expecting
like I I've only given 23 films five
stars in all I've ranked 4 600 Sun
movies I've given 23 films five stars I
expected this to be like between a four
four and a half this is a four and a
half approaching a five I don't give a
five star until the second viewing this
is this isn't my top 100 movies of all
time it's approaching like yeah I adore
this film like I it so what I love about
modern filmmaking is uh we can teach
kids what the world can be without it
feeling like a history book without it
feeling like heavy-handed and I think
that was a really important phase of us
addressing that America has not solved a
lot of its problems that we painted over
I feel like we're an apartment in
Hollywood that just like lost its
tenants in 10 years and instead of
changing the building they just painted
over it and we do a lot of that painting
over and I think that we've addressed a
lot of the obvious inequalities and
they're not solved but we've addressed
them and I and I don't think that we've
addressed the inequality of male to
female well I think we've made movies
that feel like you either an attack or a
dismission and I don't feel like this is
either and I feel like this is gonna be
really good for young boys and young
girls so to me this was a movie that was
as entertaining as it was important and
that's really hard to do
um fight club's my favorite movie of all
time but Fight Club has the worst PR in
the world fight Club is loved by the
worst people and I love that I can meet
someone and say that and they can judge
me and I can know how they see Fight
Club versus how I see Fight Club I love
that Tyler Durden is my favorite
protagonist for 10 years until I
realized he was an antagonist and then
realizing he was an antagonist made me
realize what that movie was he or Barbie
he's my Barbie 100 and then and that Ken
was Tyler made me so happy because Ken
went through his Tyler face even
visually and at one point they reference
fight club by doing the all the Ken
standing in a line in a row and they say
like something together like welcome
there's a scene so in Fight Club the
first time you see Tyler is Jack is in
his hotel and he's talking about
insomnia and Jack is laying on the couch
and he goes like he's giving a beautiful
monologue about everything blending
together when you have insomnia all
these things the first time you see Brad
Pitt in the movie isn't on the walkway
escalator at the airport it's in the
bottom right hand frame he's one of the
waiters and he goes welcome and in
Barbie they have all the Ken's line up
and do a very subtle literally seven
frame Fight Club reference to tie in
Tyler to Ken which might not have even
been intentional accepted to me I gotta
ask Greta it literally is a frame from
Fight Club acknowledging that
masculinity and what I love is that
forever this will be kind of my Fight
Club sister film like to me this is
addressing masculinity in a way that is
a film for girls but so many people get
something out of it the reason I love
Fight Club is the only person in that
movie that anchors Jack back to reality
is is the female energy of Marla and all
the masculine energy isn't negative or
inherently evil but it serves him
negatively and in this film you need to
find the female energy and the kennergy
they balance each other out and that's
so important to me so Barbie Not only
was funnier than I thought it was going
to be Not only was better than I thought
it was going to be but it meant more to
me than I thought it would and it's a
movie that I can't I don't even have
kids yet I can't wait to show my kids
that don't yet exist so like this movie
everything so you need to do Barb and
Club you need to do those two together
if I had a snesbian night if they let me
run one Hollywood Forever night I would
Barber club and I would be the most
insane nobody in the history of Cinema I
bet has ever drawn such a brilliant you
know speech first I have to be like this
is why we're here at barbin club and the
first two rules are you do talk about
bourbon Club because kids need to learn
so yeah this movie meant the world to me
and I um I loved what what Ryan brought
to it like Ryan Gosling's performance I
know there's like Oscar balls already
but what he had to do to be so masculine
in a way that some will see a
self-effacing but wasn't what he had to
do to find a way to be hyper masculine
in a way that was like comedic but never
self-deprecating to the point where it
made masculisms bad and and like as as a
very like I love the gym I love Fight
Club I love UFC I love all the things
that so many people that I respect and
admire think are evil like a lot of
people I really appreciate are like oh
that stuff all that and like I feel like
masculinity has a parentheses toxic
around it because of society right now
like it's like Fight Club we got some
bad PR guys are messing up but like this
movie made I agree with you though but I
agree there's an inherent like this is
bad and the movie you didn't ever say it
was bad it said we need to figure this
stuff out and make it work for everybody
so this movie was kind of like me going
like look see we can have a dojo house
but we need to not make sure it doesn't
get rid of the dream house like we can
have these things but find a place for
everyone and and understand that this is
a yin yang it's a symbiosis not a
parasitic relationship so
um what that was almost single-handedly
what the Ken's brought so cmo's
performance Ryan's performance obviously
amazing he was a great dancer so and
that scene like that reference like the
classic toxic era of masculinity where
they go back to like literally like
fighting and all of that waiting
commentary genius so yeah I mean I could
literally do an hour and a half on on I
love this film my the laugh out loud
moment for me was the guitars
when all the women
that they're into it because there isn't
a female out there watching that didn't
at some point in high school have a
boyfriend that was like babe listen to
me play the guitar whatever it was it
was usually the guitar I was roaring in
my theater and that was great because
it's literally guys think that is
something and we want that to mean
something exactly and I love that it
addressed that sit there and go great
and we don't thank you enough for it
honey that's the thing is that women
don't get their credit for being like
that's a weird thing then that's what
this movie did it went like hey they
should get credit for a million oh yeah
that's what it really is so many bad
guitar performers like Matchbox 20 is
fantastic for us but we know it's not
always for you but we acknowledge this
movie acknowledges like Hey we're so
sorry but also let us have this and it
doesn't say it's bad it just says like
it's different for us I loved it I I
Adore this film yeah I mean this is one
of those films and we're gonna get into
the award season talk at the very end of
this after we talk about Oppenheimer but
I think you're going to be hearing
barberheimer at the Oscars it's going to
be a barberheimer Oscar I want County
junior V Ryan Gosling for the opposite
Road that's gonna be a showdown for the
ages like that's almost like I mean the
last time Downey Jr was up for the Oscar
I believe was for Tropic Thunder
opposite Heath Ledger's Joker it's
almost that level of duality of in the
same performances 2008 you know what
would be even better than them both
getting nominated if they died oh you
know what bump up Gosling to best lead
and then the town is supporting and
that's the double win Ken has to be
supporting that doesn't no no that is
the point for the sake of the walk away
but it's arguable it is arguable that it
is a lead role it's hard to say because
it defined lead versus supporting
because it's the lead of that side of
the film but it's a supporting role to
Barbie being yes he's not just Ken he is
knuff
he is he is more than he's more than
enough
um I need that sweater Mattel please
send me that sweater by the way speaking
of Mattel they've got some other toy
movies in the works and if they're this
good we're in for it twice on Hot Wheels
yeah JJ Abrams right JJ Abrams is doing
the Hot Wheels one Daniel kaluya is
doing Barney
and then Vin Diesel is doing is it
Rock'em sock'em I don't know they did
with Real Steel with um that was an
adaptation of uh with Sean Levy and Hugh
Jackman remember the but I think they're
doing one they're doing a more literal
one oh fascinating I mean good for them
I I want the shared Universe this toy
shared universe so what do you like
moving forward do you think I mean it's
not going to just be Mattel it's going
to be do you think Hollywood is just
going to start because it's obviously
we're into Nostalgia right now right
between Super Mario Brothers and Barbie
what how do you think Studios sort of
lean into this in the right way because
you can't just say oh we're gonna make
more toys people just want more toy
movies it's the fact that this is such a
good toy I have Lord and Miller consult
that's the first step
um but I I think Nostalgia can be
wielded correctly because what Nostalgia
is to me is US acknowledging that we
felt better about our past and we don't
know what our future is the uncertainty
of our future is what oppenheimer's
about which we're about to get into but
I think as long as you look back with
the lens of how do we remind ourselves
what worked about that time to make our
future better not just looking back I
think a big problem that America has is
we go like remember when things were
good and we we remember the Now That's
What I Call Music version of it there
were lots of bad songs on with these
good songs there were lots of bad times
for a lot of people things we thought
were good were happening if we look back
at the 50s we'd be like yeah like
burners were this much 12 cents for a
comic book all these things yeah but
like people were not allowed to drink
out of the same water fountains like
there was so much wrong that we just go
like this was good for blank and so like
the in this much to a much less
important sense if we look back at
movies with too much Nostalgia then we
just go like remember when things were
great yeah but this was happening to our
economy this was happening to a certain
group of people this was how we
perceived a certain group of people so I
think Nostalgia should be used as a
weapon of achieving the feeling of good
but with the knowledge of progress so
that's what Barbie did Barbie went like
remember how great this was let's go
forward the fact that leaned so heavily
into their Vision yeah made it a film
for adults make Hot Wheels about
improving the way we handle emissions
make Hot Wheels about like how important
it is to get the word out about like
Evie being a problem for certain lithium
issues but also solving this issues make
make uh Rock'em sock'em about like you
know concussion trauma but how important
important is for fighters to have an
outlet to fight like you know the whole
point of Rock'em sock'em is you hit him
enough and their head pops off make it
about like you know something yeah I
don't know you literally had these two
little things press press you hit him
enough their head pops off you rock them
sock them so I would literally make a
movie that is a commentary on how like
some people innately need to fight there
are people born out of time there are
people that like actual Warriors of UFC
that is what their art is that is what
their their thing is and we judge them
for it make a commentary on how
brutality has its place and how we need
to have a place for this in society for
people and call it Rock 'em sock'em
robots like there's ways to make all
these movies commentary but still tied
to the IP still give us little
references still make it work but make
them more important than just a toy
movie and then we'll show up because
it's actually an undercurrent of
importance with the shiny object that it
is the one thing that makes me excited
is knowing JJ Abrams I read an article
where he said it took him three years
to sort of go oh now I know a way into
the story that's very much darker story
than he originally anticipated and that
he wasn't going to do it unless he
really knew how to approach it and he's
like I got it now history and NASCAR is
crazy like we literally invented cars
that could outrun police cars because of
prohibition make Hot Wheels a commentary
on like the police state like there's
things you can do it's right there like
the the American Pastime of racing cars
came out of them trying to escape cops
like make something that's looking at
the way we live in an authoritarian
police state and make it about us trying
to get our power back as Citizens like
there's a lot and that's what Barbie did
essentially that's what Barbie did and
that's why it's that's why it's again
and we'll go into Nolan in a second
Nolan always says he gives his audience
credit for being so smart and Barbie did
that too yeah at no point that I feel
like I was being pandered to no and the
nice thing is though like you know the
audience reaction to it it being 90 when
I saw it I saw it a few days before it
opened and I'm always a little bit
nervous when somebody takes a big swing
like that of people going to embrace it
and the fact that they are smart enough
to get it and know what it is and that
it appeals to everybody is you mentioned
the the Montage at the end yeah like
what you identified with him with your
mom and everything else yeah it just it
just hit me in an emotional way there
was just something about it that just it
was like a gut punch of you being a
woman in this industry that is so so
tricky for women was the element of I
won the Helen Mirren joke the like
casting Margaret Robbie is exactly wrong
for this but was were there elements of
the weird Barbie Normal Barbie uh the
stereotypical Barbie other Barbies like
the the everyone's important everyone's
a Barbie like how did that resonate for
you having been in the industry and seen
that be the opposite like is there so
much like you have to be this this year
you've got to be this this season you've
got to be like the movie was about
everyone should be able to play all toys
I will say this so before I was a host I
was a model and I was never in fashion
oh I was never in fashion it was always
oh this year it's this look or this year
it's this look and I never felt like
yeah I felt accepted because I made my
living that way and of course you're
your your worth comes from within but I
was never The It Girl does that make
sense so if that sort of is a reflect
and I think that was it's kind of the
same as hosting sometimes they're
looking for this or sometimes they're
looking looking for that sometimes they
want actors hosting sometimes they want
comedians hosting so you're always it's
it's it always and it's not about gender
because I've never sort of I've just
sort of always just done my thing and of
course there's going to be obstacles in
the way whether it's that you're female
or whether it's something else that's in
your way it's it's always like oh I'm
just not the it girl of the moment I've
never felt like I was maybe this is my
moment
this is it I'll be wearing pink for the
next five years oh you know that's good
that's the season you're now that you
are the it no and that's the thing is a
lot of my hosting gigs I dress very very
girly and I'm like now I can finally oh
that's so cool yeah so that did like hit
like that was a it did but like I said
like I never had
I never had
um and maybe that's why that moment like
you said hit me because I never had a
complicated relationship with Barbie and
that was the moment that I understood I
think that a lot of people did yeah does
that make sense no no you're
experiencing something but seeing others
it felt like that was the moment where
it transitioned from being my Barbie
movie to everybody's Barbie movie I love
that I'm gonna make myself cry right now
that's so great I love that I love that
okay I just forget to do the critics
consensus for Barbie so let's finish on
that the critics consensus is Barbie is
a visually dazzling comedy whose meta
humor is smartly complimented by
subversive storytelling
um couldn't concur more and we will get
into award season talk at the end of
this because I have a lot to say about
that too
are you ready to often let's Oppenheimer
second half of the day let's get into it
ding second round okay like I mentioned
earlier Tomato Meter score matched the
audience score these two are the cutest
ever
um the critics consensus Oppenheimer
marks another engrossing achievement
from Christopher Nolan that benefits
from Murphy's tour de force performance
and stunning visuals
um your overall thoughts on Oppenheimer
I meant to ask you your ranking of
credit gerwig's films but obviously
Barbie's your number one oh yeah it's
it's literally like it's my favorite I
love Greta go away yeah but I don't
often find myself like seeking out a
re-watch I like when I'm in the theater
I have a time and like I but like I'm
not gonna watch Little Women every
Christmas like I'll probably watch
Barbie every summer yeah you know what I
mean like there's just an impact and
that's no uh Shaden heard just this one
hit me in a personal way Oppenheimer is
very interesting in that I will probably
re-watch this the least of Nolan's films
but but I can acknowledge it's probably
the most technically perfect so I can
acknowledge that like it might be his
Masterpiece but my experience of it was
so
negative in a positive way I felt so
much more than I was comfortable with I
was so impacted by the atrocities of man
that I didn't enjoy myself watching it
uh and maybe that was especially
interesting with the duality of my
experience with Barbie where I was like
we're gonna make it we got this everyone
and then I let Barbie like we've just
gone too far like so my experience with
Nolan films are are usually a
kind of paranoid
oppressive police state surveillance
uncomfortable like I love that Dark
Knight acknowledges what we were going
through
um you know with surveillance in a very
interesting way where Batman's like this
is too much power for one man to have
and I love that Dark Knight Rises
acknowledge that like having everyone
surveilled and under the scrutiny of
this militant regime is no way to live
and freedom is actually being able to be
your own person and I love that you know
Memento is about like if your memories
aren't even yours like what do you
identify with as a person like who are
you without your journey and your
memories and your experience all of
Nolan's The Prestige is such a beautiful
commentary on what it is to even be
human and what yourself even is as a
commentary so Nolan's very personal to
me um I love Nolan's work Oppenheimer
was truly an experience of borderline
nihilism of you know the human genius
has always been corrupted and I think
that every genius that you know we've
lived through is is a terrifying
commentary in the way we we lead
ourselves like The Social Network I
think is the greatest horror movie the
last 40 years the social network is
literally how when we connect it should
be a force of good and look what we made
social media and I feel like Oppenheimer
is using some of that same commentary on
this is a man who was able to smash the
atom using theoretical math and was able
to in his head go that's what is
possible and then we were able to build
it that is alchemy that is Magic that is
and then we turn it into a weapon and
then we put it upon people that were not
deserving that we're not even it's a
commentary on the destruction
destructive nature of man to a scale
that is so horrific that when you hear
the numbers at the end of the film it's
a toss away and I think that was very
conscious we killed hundreds of
thousands of people and ruined millions
of lives and we did it as a political
Ploy and we did it we we crossed out one
of 12 cities because someone wanted a
vacation there and I do perceive human
nature as that flippant about lives so
the idea that someone can be so genius
that they can change the world in a way
that they felt like they had to just so
someone else didn't change the world
first and it wasn't at us the idea that
all the most genius people of their time
can gather together and literally build
a city and then build something in that
City that's going to irreparably become
the new state of warfare we're just
really really really smart Apes with
sticks and the bigger we make our sticks
the more Apes we can take out and this
was such a fascinating
uncomfortable journey of perfect
filmmaking telling the perfect story of
how perfectly messed up we are and so I
won't find myself going like you know
I'ma put on that cautionary tale again
because it's too late it's not even a
cautionary tale and and the closest we
have to it is the last five minutes
being like you know what I think they
were right we did destroy the planet
with this tool I think that's around the
corner with AI I think that's around the
corner with what we've built we have so
rapidly gone from
the age of connect us all through
connecting us all has made us hate each
other through we have to try to
reconnect with each other because of
situations out of our control okay now
we're reconnecting let's figure out how
to do it and take away art from artists
let's take away the only thing that
makes us human is our ability to cause
other people's emotion the thing that we
live to die but the point is the life
that we live should impact others in a
positive way we don't often so this
movie is that to me and I think that
this is going to be much the way the
social network is to me the horror movie
the last 20 years because it was so
prophetic towards what was to come this
to me feels like a commentary on what's
about to come and it scares the crap out
of me because this movie is about a time
eight years ago or 60 years ago so this
movie was hard to watch because it was
so good and uh I I hate love it
no it makes sense and I agree I agree
with the first thing that you said about
Technically when people say I hate when
people use the word Masterpiece sure
because it's subjective it's just that
word it's like I think a masterpiece
usually has to have age behind it right
you can't call something a masterpiece
like when Van Gogh painted like you
can't say the next day that's a
masterpiece or maybe somebody did at
that time
slow down
I think technically it was magnificent I
think if this doesn't win the Oscar for
screenwriting there is something wrong I
mean I know I haven't seen everything
that comes out is coming out this year
killers of the flower Moon there's gonna
be all kinds of stuff but it is so
brilliant
um I watched an interview that just
floored me if you've watched any of the
interviews that
um Christopher Nolan and Robert Downey
Jr did together did you see where Robert
Downey Jr said he went in for ADR which
ADR for people who don't know is like
usually after a film I'm sure most
people watching this know this you go
and you do anything that wasn't captured
on the day technically there could have
been something flying by or you have to
redo your lines yeah and usually on a
film of this size especially like a
superhero film or something with a lot
going on it would be pages and pages of
ADR and you'd be there for hours Robert
Downey Jr had one line of ADR because
Christopher Nolan is such a technician
there was nothing wrong on the day
nothing had to be done and the only line
was a lot find that Nolan had originally
written to the script and taken out and
then decided he wanted to put back in
one line and it had nothing to do with
like technically they didn't get it on
the day incredible isn't that amazing
that's I mean he's saying and that is
this film and there has been nothing
more
exciting for my love Nolan and uh also
he's a hero and he's just
um this is it is so it makes me so proud
I'm gonna start crying talking about
this but it makes me so proud to see so
many people embracing this movie I
didn't even talk about the records that
it broke for adult drama three hours
adult drama the number one R-rated movie
of the weekend since 2019's Joker wow
and that's a hell of an IP the biggest
worldwide opening for a biographical
film it beat out Bohemian Rhapsody
previously had that record thank you
and that to me
gives me so much hope and we knew Barbie
was going to be a hit right right
but the fact that people are coming out
of this movie and I've spent days
Googling days Googling everything that
happened in his life and that's what a
great film obviously does and I can't
remember I think it might have been
Bohemian Rhapsody the last time that I
did that yeah and that's a fun overall
there's obviously darkness in it but you
go into that movie for a Concert
Experience yeah you don't go into
opinion but dread yeah and I do think
and there one criticism that I keep
hearing over and over is that he didn't
show the atrocities of what the bomb did
um and and I thought he did I thought
the scene he showed the body on the
ground even even the mental the mental
experience of what he went through I
felt like really encapsulated I think if
we left Oppenheimer because we don't
leave Oppenheimer much I think if we
left Oppenheimer and went to Nagasaki or
went to Hiroshima it would have been
almost
gratuitously
profiteering off their deaths I agree
and instead we have an experience where
he's being applauded and the silence is
the atrocity when he's being applauded
it turns into screams or when he's being
applauded and then he sees their faces
melting to me that was not
grandstanding off of the horrors we've
done it was showing that he was
realizing in real time this is the rest
of his life he's gonna live with these
nightmares he's gonna he's gonna endure
that he did this and he Nolan as you
know shoots everything practically he
puts everything in the camera if he was
going to take footage from way back and
throw it into the movie I don't know it
would have lost
the message the continuity and grotesque
people dying that really died and it was
he it was the first script he wrote in
the first person this was Robert
oppenheim this is what he would have
experienced in his world he was not
their eyes he was not there they could
have showed him watching a news
broadcast sure but seeing what his his
imagination was what was happening in
his imagination and what I think is so
fascinating is how this is a human
tragedy like you said this was a
scientist yeah
who
was so incredibly brilliant like you
said like started out his career
splitting atoms and that was his focus
and he wasn't involved in politics and
he wasn't involved with war he was
brought into this whole thing and what I
mean he died very very young and it
didn't and obviously was plagued for the
rest of his life by what happened and I
kept thinking the one takeaway I had
from this was we now have the
perspective in 2023 that no we have not
had a nuclear Annihilation yeah
he didn't know that right what he was
living with up until his death and what
was going on in the world and he was
I'm sure certain that he had caused
immediate nuclear Annihilation I'm sure
he he really felt that that was within
the scope of of realities
like that we talk about the codes we
talk about nuclear like it's still and
this is a lot later decades later so I I
absolutely agree but I think he probably
felt like it was imminent yeah
immediately imminent and living with
that and I thought they did a great job
making his theatricality and his
penchant for verbosity so much a part of
how this happened I like that his
arrogance was part of how this occurred
was him being like I want to be the guy
I want to be the famous one and how that
was weaponized by Downey's character but
also in a way that like I think you know
Matt Damon's character weaponized as
well I think it was really interesting
how the all things had to line up to
allow Oppenheimer to exist exactly how
he was his womanizing his pension for
making irrational decisions all of that
led to the bomb and it might not have
occurred before because one of the only
times we heard about the Russians was
them going the wrong away with something
like one of the only times we heard
about something that was getting close
was that element and it's also really
interesting how you know some hosts are
are saying like well yeah you should
have had his uh clearance taken away
like you know the Communist ties and all
that stuff and it's so interesting how
there's so much ingrained fear of
certain elements that never left us from
that time like you say the word
communist and a lot of people use it as
a buzzword and don't look into the the
time and how they you know people were
treated and then like judged and labeled
and like how some people weren't and
they were labeled as this thing and then
people also don't look at like the
ramifications of people leaving that
that era and you know we're seeing so
much now where people are put into
tribes because we're so tribal as people
and we're so much more connected and I
feel like we're entering an era of your
blank this is a problem you're blank
this is a problem and it mirrors that
world and it's a very cautionary tale
even beneath the nukes and I feel like
all the Communist allegory is is very
indicative of what we could become very
quickly again today and it really scares
me that nobody's talking about that
they're talking about they didn't show
this they didn't have this they didn't
have this I'm like yeah but this is a
cautionary tarot and like 15 levels yeah
and they did and he didn't hit you over
the head like a lot of films might label
this guy a womanizer and it would have
been very exploitative or it would have
been oh he was a good guy or a bad guy
he showed the complexity of a human of a
human being put in that situation who
are the other standouts for you
um I mean this cashier it's insane he's
like it took me a second I have to be
honest there was a couple people because
there were so many people popping on and
off screen sure I was like oh there's
Rami Malek oh there's Matt Damon and
then I would settle into it but because
people would kind of pop in yeah okay
okay for a second take me out of it yeah
because yeah and then I personally but I
get it yeah uh I'm gonna be totally
biased and shame is the name drop I got
three buddies in this movie so like oh
my God uh can I can I try to pick oh
that'd be awesome because and and for me
it was this is a point of pride of just
seeing uh friends that did such
exceptional work that like I I got to
see people that I know and care about
and no one if your buddies with Jason
Clarke that'd be great though I've loved
him for so long I thought he was okay my
favorite performance was a Redemption
for some bull that wasn't his fault and
Josh uh Alden so Alden I feel like Alden
really got to show people who he is as
an actor because alden's incredible he's
always been great but I think so I don't
know that's what I mean Redemption
because it's not on like but he was good
at it what are you talking about the
amount like what he had to disappear
like I just feel like Alden well you
went through it with him I'm sure I was
there when he got like soloed like so so
um basically for me laugh now because
he's still in cocaine bear too um to me
Alden is like one of the greatest
talents of Our Generation and I feel
like there was a time where people were
only gonna know him as that Huntsville
movie that didn't work out so I like
Beautiful Creatures he's great in he's
been so good for long enough that I was
like this will blow over and when it
didn't I was like oh if we lose one of
the great actors of our time due to
things out of his control due to two
sets of directors due to Studio stuff
that would have been a like a shame so
maybe it was my personal investment but
mostly it was like this guy's too
talented to not be revered and he's like
acting around Downey like doing circles
around and keeping up like sparring in
the room with this incredible
performance that down he's giving that's
insane
um The Great and super underrated Scotty
Grimes is literally uh he grew up three
streets for me uh so Scotty Grimes was
when I told people I was moving to
Hollywood the only person that ever made
it out was Scott so he was like we've
known you we've only known each other a
couple years now but he was always that
figurehead of like you can get out and
be like Scott so like it was like what
do you play remind everybody he was the
other guy in the room at Downey uh and
Alden so I got to see two people I know
opposite Downey incredible work like
truly seeing what did they say about
Downey behind the scenes come on force
of Nature and like they were so
intimidated but so impressed at how much
like he just connects unreal he's unreal
and if you again watch any of the press
that he has done
how off the cuff freaking funny this man
is the stuff that comes out of his mouth
the stuff that he comes up against type
making him someone you're like okay I
keep wanting to like him but he's
messing up I keep wanting to like him
but he's the problem I loved that choice
well the other thing I love I want to
point out technically what I loved about
between the two hearings I know they
were shot one black and you know black
and white and you went back forth black
and white to color but what I loved was
the Oppenheimer hearing the set
decoration they made it as Bland as it
would be in real life so many times in
films you see a courtroom or a hearing
room and if you've ever been to in a
courtroom not that I've been into a many
but if you've ever walked into one
they're never Grand they look like they
don't have a room a room with an ugly
ass tape and then showing the setup for
like three friends sitting around a
small a table and how claustrophobic
that felt and then my favorite favorite
thing that he did and my favorite
moments of the movie were just seeing
people testify and seeing Oppenheimer
slouched behind that person and
listening and watching everything his
eyes on his face yeah and how he got
defeated and how he wouldn't fight for
himself and everything that was oh my
God what I love that the black and white
shot that it was objective versus
subjective yeah like the color versus
black and white I love that everything
that was provable and on film and things
that occurred on the record were black
and white and I love that everything
that was someone's emotional experience
that was color like I thought that was
so jealous because because our emotions
are in color when you remember
emotionality it's in color when you
remember facts it's in black and white
so we've shot the film facts were black
and white and color was emotional
experience and how the color and the
emotion is what shaped how we got to the
bomb okay who's your third friend and
I'm gonna tell you my favorite
performance and aside from Killian
Murphy so much love for Jack Wade Jack
is Rich yeah Jack is one of the greatest
uh I think
Jack is such a unique force in film
because Jack is always that guy you're
like man he seems awesome and I want to
know and I love that they made him the
guy that was like I'm really good at
science and I'm really bad so who did he
play uh he's the one that looks through
the the most memorable moment was he's
looking through the windshields like I
don't need the goggles I got the
windshield that's fine so he's the
scientist that's kind of like I'm really
a genius but I'm Gonna Keep like
dropping the ball in certain you know
logical science choices okay um but what
I love about Jack is whenever he shows
up at a movie I personally immediately
am always like I'd watch that movie like
I'd go off on that journey and find out
how he got in that room he brings so
much history and so much experience and
in real life Jack is maybe the kindest
person I've met in this industry like
Jack we literally I was doing press at
prey and Jack crashed my interview like
me and him started quoting Paul Rudd
memes at each other across the red
carpet and then he came over and jumped
in my interview and did a whole thing
together because Jack's just the kind of
guy that's like let's make this bigger
and more exciting and let's do a thing
and Jack is such a kind soul that it
actually translates on screen like not a
lot of people that are that kind do
immediately go like I wanna know more
about them because he's so good that it
translates it's like a Chris Pratt kind
of energy but I think this movie needed
that and I think casting Jack was genius
and I think Matt Damon too Matt Damon
had that energy friendly Tommy Lee Jones
yes
no and I thought he was the part he was
another one he came on screen I was like
okay is he gonna take me out of this
because it's Matt Damon because he's so
good it's just there was something about
this film that it was just
and maybe it's because he didn't cast a
huge movie star like a well-known
revered actor but not a movie star that
when the movie star started started to
pop in but speaking of movie stars and I
hate to be bring up you know I don't
want to sound like I'm only saying this
because she was she's a woman Emily
Blunt's scene holy Bonkers one of the
best scenes in the film in a film of
scenes so
I almost forgot because Emily Blunt has
done so many commercial films in the
last couple years I almost forgot what a
great actress she is yeah I mean you
know she's an she's a movie star as we
say sometimes we say people have a movie
star quality and she has it in Spades
but it reminded me when she sat there
and I'd fellow actor told me this that
they've studied Emily Blunt because
she's their favorite actor and when she
one thing you learn as an actor is how
to actively listen to somebody and not
just be like deer in headlights waiting
for their next line
and what she does is she puts her tongue
on the inside of her mouth goes like
this and it's the first time she ever
put her tongue on the outside of her
mouth so she's like licking her lips
when he's talking at her the Jason Clark
character and like she just knows she
has him she has them and she's milking
that moment and she's like I'll let you
finish sweetie
she's licking her chops and then she
unleashes that was the moment of the
film for me I was like give this woman
how much news up there was to that
moment because we'd seen all the moments
between her and Oppenheimer and we'd
seen their relationship and then when
when she's so frustrated with him and
the prosecutor being like I mean and the
defender uh the defendant lawyer what do
they call those not the prosecutor the
guy on your side the guy defending you
is he uh defense attorney right yeah
when the defense attorney was like are
you sure you want her up there and then
you stop and everything like oh more
than anything I know this and then she
does that you're like yes that whole
relationship in one scene you get it and
you get why the floor and few
relationship doesn't make sense you get
why the womanizing all of the past
doesn't make sense and then the bond of
them together when he's laying outside
and she finds him using the edit that
way to cut back to that scene I thought
that flashbacks usually don't work for
me this movie used flashback so well
that it didn't make the audience feel
dumb it enhanced the memory my favorite
thing about memory is like you could
remember something and be like all right
that's why that was important to me but
then you can have one thing spark an
addition to that memory and then it
connects the memory and it
re-contextualizes your whole experience
because of the way our brains work like
our frontal yeah like it attaches
differently to the back of our brain
where we store memories and then you can
cause new neural Pathways the movie is
edited that way the movie is edited to
allow you to understand different
experiences with a memory that doesn't
feel like shoehorned in it's not like
yeah you didn't get it it's like here's
some more data it's the the editing as
much as the screenwriting yeah is in
Chrome casting like I talked about
Jack's warmth also Scott his abilities
this isn't even the whole cap that's
insane so without Jack's warmth there
wouldn't have been someone that you were
like rooting for even though they were a
little not as smart with the social cues
without Alden being so deliberate and
calculating you wouldn't have cared
about someone that was you know danced
around Danny Jr without Scots warmth
that didn't have a lot of screen time
but whenever he delivered without David
de smalchin who's so I love him good
every time but maybe his least creepy
character like David's so good at being
that guy they're like I don't trust him
he played like a guy in this but because
it's David you've had this like
undercurrent of like I don't like
everything he's doing to my guy because
of how he's playing this the casting in
this made you the against type Downey
the somewhat against type Florence Pew
everyone in this had exactly the purpose
that their energy brought and that it
was written for them in a way that I
couldn't see anyone else in any of these
roles it was genius like the casting the
editing the writing the directing like
that's how I hate love it also
Oppenheimer Killian Murphy wasn't bad
the first meeting performance since 28
Days Later I think I think so well if
he's first with for sure with Nolan for
sure they've worked together so many
people under sees the lead but like I
feel like we have another leading movie
with him since 28 Days Later yeah and I
feel like he was comfortable with that
oh so so much three hours of comfort
that's what I like most about his
performance is that he almost played it
like a supporting actor does that make
sense in that he didn't overdo anything
and he didn't overcook anything he
didn't over dramatize he didn't indicate
you know when actors indicate an emotion
he just felt the emotion because the
audience picks up on subtlety the
subtlety of the performance is what made
it a chef's kiss and the fact that we
watched a guy that invented the atomic
bomb we felt
sympathy and we also felt empathy two
very different emotions so I had my
Barbie cry moment in this movie and that
was in the years later when they aged
them up and he gets his award finally
and you and in that flash I got the
years that he went through yeah to get
to that moment because we've we've we've
seen that before in Hollywood everywhere
where somebody is vilified or whatever
and I'm not saying that he was a hero
but were somebody for years even Alden
to a certain degree and then they
finally have their moment and I really
do believe that usually that does happen
it might be 20 years later it might be
30 years later it might be a year later
but the fact that he had that moment I
burst into tears and the fact that we
have in life experienced as viewers
award ceremonies and knowing something
felt off the simple line of like know
that it's for you and not know that's
for them not for you know that they're
giving the award to get rid of their
guilt not for you to receive it and how
real that feels and how much that
affects the entire experience of award
shows something we do with how that
affects people's guilt when you see
people get like VFW Awards and stuff
it's for the giver not as much the
receiver a lot of the time yes the
Oscars honorary award yeah they're like
oh sorry we messed up for 30 years old
and Best Supporting too just because I I
want that dude let's start out this
conversation by saying that Christopher
Dolan was never nominated for best
director for Inception
wow I didn't realize I believe he was
his first nomination was for Dunkirk as
a director I think only yeah only
Shenanigans bananas this one so with
that he will 100 get nominated yeah I
mean sure as sugar this man is getting a
nomination this is this is a definite
best picture nominee and let's bring
Barbie into this conversation too as an
overall because I do believe that
there's going to be in barbenheimer
Oscars yeah I think it's our pink horse
do we feel that Barbie's getting a best
picture Nam yes yes when I don't think
but I think it'll be worthy of the
campaign alone for our joy but I I don't
uh I'm gonna be this year's Top Gun
where people are like it was commercial
it was tossed away because it was
commercial even though it was a great
film and it also came out in the summer
we'll get a nom yeah and I think I think
she will too I think No One's Gonna Get
the win but that might also be some
Legacy do you think he's gonna win yeah
okay
I haven't
he has one but I mean it's really hard
to say I haven't seen it I haven't yeah
I've only seen the trailer yeah uh but I
do think that Nolan has only gotten the
one um I do think that this is the
talked about movie of what this movie
represents I think this is the oh my God
I'm at 82 million it's an adult drama
this is the we can make films that
aren't just IP you know it's that movie
so I think that's why he gets it for a
lot of reasons and it's deserved like
it's not like you get it because of like
thanks but like oh my God you made this
art right but I I don't know if Barbie
will get that Top Gun approach where it
gets all these things I think I think
Gosling might actually genuinely get the
win you do I do I I think it's above
Downey Jr because they would both be in
supporting assuming they both go in
supporting I don't think that that
Ryan's going in lead for cash I don't
think so either but I do think that
supporting might go to because it's
dramatic it's comedic it's a lot it's
like he's I I don't I I think he could
get it like it's so memorable like I
don't think I've seen a performance like
that that left me since Downey and
Tropic Thunder is there a meme like a
barberheimer meme for those two being
nominated
what would it be
Robert Downey Robert Downey Junior
but I really want to see that because
it's so pink and so black and white yeah
like we barely saw him in color I'd love
the bigness of Ken and the and the
Darkness 100 but I honestly think they
could be the Two Front Runners and I
could see I could see Ryan pulling it
out at the end yeah but I I also like I
want I'm just so happy for Downey
because
I love Marvel if you know me you know I
love it yeah we know this I am so tired
of Downey being Tony Stark to everyone
that man is such a champion actor Beyond
Iron Man Kiss Kiss Bang Bang I think is
a is a better movie than any of the Iron
Man's I'm saying it on camera I think
that chaplain is one of the best
performances of all time I think that
what down he's able to do outside of
Tony Stark is as good oh yeah and thus I
100 think I've never even post on
Instagram people are just like oh
there's my Tony Stark I'm like no it
sounds well I was just praying during
this whole thing that people wouldn't
bring up Iron Man and make the
comparison like in his interviews like
just don't even ask about it no no he
didn't yeah we all know he did it what
are you gonna ask that's why I don't
want him or Chris Evans come back I I
honestly I know they're going to beg in
secret world because they probably will
but I I would rather Chris Evans get to
be an actor in Downey Jr that's where I
disagree I want them always to come back
I always want sequels I always want
spin-offs I'm never like leave it alone
don't touch it don't do another one
Barbie two here we go I'm like reboot
even my favorite movie because worst
case it's bad it'll make people love
mine more
and I want
um
who rediscovers the DeLorean I've
pitched this to the producers I've told
them this Frank Marshall I was like
Frank reboot this he modeled his whole
performance in Spider-Man after Marty
McFly he is a baby Marty with a time
machine yeah we digress Michael your Fox
would be the best let's go back award
season four sequels and sequels too
um so what else do we I mean production
design for Barbie costuming for Barbie
hair and makeup for Barbie does Margo
get a Best Actress nomination
she should
um it's interesting that everyone's
talking about Ryan Gosling but I think
Margo's seen on the bench does not get
enough conversation
um the your beautiful moment with the
older woman that human moment
um she goes through this incredible
realization in that crazy to us want to
Space Odyssey sequence of like you know
what it is to be a person and like going
through the pain of being alive but the
beauty of being alive like all that's
Margo like all that's her performance
but I don't know if it was
it's funny that in a movie that's as
flashy as it is I don't know if that
performance is flashy enough for people
to realize how deep that performance is
well and that's the thing she's so
perfect yeah for it and perfect in it
that it's almost seamless you don't see
the work it's like Helen Mirren saying
like she was the wrong because yeah and
that's the problem that she might have
faced the Oscars because it's like oh we
found a literal Barbie who's actually
that talented Barbie's made I'm just no
there's work can we just also give her
credit for the fact that she produced
this movie she is the one that she knew
made this whole thing happened and
that's so incredible yeah and she said
America Ferreira does she get a
nomination she was pretty great I also
love that they did the bait and switch
where it was America ferreira's memories
but they didn't make it a Young America
Ferrera I like that they they moved
their expectations really smart because
I was like oh no we're seeing a girl
that looks a lot like a young American
for oh the kid that's way better because
a lesser film would have been like it
was actually her memories and they'd be
like oh don't Pander but instead it was
like a mom and daughter story that's way
more about like empowering women that
are a multi-generational journey as
opposed to just let's go back to the
before times then that would have been
Nostalgia 100 loved that um one category
I know they won't overlap is score and
song I think Ryan could get I am just
kenson scoring this yeah Donald Glover
Ludwig is the one who makes a lot of
Donald Glover's beats metamodernism is
as alive and well with liberts and
sounds I think the score to this movie
is is enough that I probably will never
like run to it because I would feel like
the horrors like it feels so oppressive
and ominous and like dark yeah so yeah
score for uh Oppenheimer editing for
Oppenheimer yeah director for
Oppenheimer yes
um I I honestly I mean biases aside
Alden best supporting the movie's
anchored on a lot of that performance I
don't think he's getting enough talks
you know people are talking are them a
lot and they're also talking about
um
I'm so bad with names I couldn't even
think of Tom Holland
um
they're also who else are they talking
about
what's where is he I can't find him it's
all good him but not just Alden who's
the other actor he's not on my tip sheet
here which uh what performance was he
what do you do in the film and I can't
think of the the the name okay it's all
good but yeah I think there's a lot of
uh best supporting and then I mean
obviously I think Killian Murphy I don't
think I've seen a performance as good as
his that I can think of off the top of
my head for lead yeah like that was a an
insane before we carried a three-hour
movie about the atomic bomb he carried a
movie that was all Exposition this movie
has one action sequence and it's silent
and then deafening sound of horror like
that is a exposition-based performance
that he somehow carries for a very long
run time that's a season of most shows
isn't it amazing that we've talked about
this whole whole thing and not even
referenced the scene with the bomb you
knew where I was going with that isn't
that funny that's that's the part of
this movie yeah and that's so on his
shoulders and he's Josh Hartnett oh my
God he's so good because maybe also I
haven't seen him for a while but he
looks like a baby Aaron Sorkin now I was
like is that is that a d aged Aaron
sword yeah like Redford Vibes he gave me
like 70s 80s Redford Vibes where he has
that you walk in you're like guys and
the quality I love about Redford is that
he doesn't seem like he's acting he's
effortless and he had that quality in
this movie and everyone directed by like
I think one of the powers of Nolan as a
director is everyone in this movie
delivered a very very this is me living
my life I've got more life when I leave
this Frame I'm bringing life to the
scene but everything is not just
effortless it's got weight of History to
it and not in the historical sense in
the literal character sense yeah and I
think Nolan is is so good at making
actors
um present and one of the inside
baseball here
um I've worked with Nolan I was in Dark
Knight Rises very briefly and to see his
work uh sorry somebody buried the lead
I'm sorry I've already name dropped
three actors I'm trying to not do it
more but I've got to see Nolan work
firsthand so it was really amazing to
get to be on a set with Nolan and watch
a moment so I got to watch Nolan work so
is it what everybody says where he just
all of a sudden you're filming he
doesn't go actually it's not a big thing
he just kind of leads into it there's a
scene that I'm in in Dark Knight Rises
that I didn't know they were filming
uh there's a scene when there's two of
Bane's henchmen looking around and they
see a stack of cars in the distance and
they shot an IMAX camera I didn't know
that that was in the movie until I
watched the movie in theaters I went hey
it was me like I'm literally it's it's
four seconds but I knew because I was
the one going like there's a scene of a
bunch of cars stacked up showing that
the city's blocked off in IMAX this
beautiful shot had no idea so like the
way he directs is incredible because he
trusts his casting trusts his actors and
then his notes are really beautifully
subtle and like he'll just do a couple
takes then it'll be like sentence
sentence sentence back to video did he
give you a note uh I think the one note
he gave was I was in a scene where they
let a guy fall through the ice and Dark
Knight Rises uh as like banishment or
Exile or death or Exile was the scene
and um there was a moment where I was
looking and I think he came over and
just said uh more cautious as in like I
was a threat to go to like he just gave
me the note that like me watching this
wasn't I wasn't safe because someone
else was going out it was that like I
could be next and I hadn't considered
that because I was like I'm Justin this
scene like over here but he was like he
knew that everyone in the frame would be
analyzed he knew that his frame was so
important that like I don't even speak
in that scene but he said more cautious
because he wanted like even if it just
panned by me the fear of the
oppressiveness of Bane to always be
present so that one light it was two
words and I was like great note and like
it changed my whole dynamic of my entire
character and that was like watching him
work was always that um so to see Alden
who I did David Mammoth speed the plow
with uh once and so just that's a hell
of a dense language play yeah to see
Alden get to do what I think he's so
good at which is handled so much
dialogue in a way that doesn't feel
heavy handy don't feel the paragraphs
and all the next right and to see Nolan
who doesn't let that ever feel like not
natural that's why I think the
performances this are so great because
he's so good at directing with
minimalist shaping and then these actors
are also good at delivering this this
could fight 200 pages long like it's so
dense well that's why I could never be
an actor just the memorization I can't
even memorize one damage
um uh we have already gone over time
so much to talk about I feel like we've
only scratched the surface it was
relevant I was trying to knock you
didn't at all there was no name dropping
it was fascinating and now I'm gonna
like pick your brain for another hour
before I let you leave
as always just a joy to talk to you koi
is a joy I said this last time but you
are I truly are let everybody know where
they can find you oh you got me down on
Tick Tock Instagram Twitter YouTube
Every social media at koi johndro and on
YouTube I uh I'm trying to get people
into comic books themselves the actual
Comics so I'm giving people about 60
years worth of comic book knowledge and
about 40 to 50 seconds where if you like
a character I'm going like hey did you
enjoy this and then my favorite of their
Comics relating to that take on that
character so you can literally uh I went
to a comic store in San Diego and they
called me oh you're that pointing guy
because people have been coming in and
going like what are these Comics I want
to find them oh that's so nice and I'm
really trying to get people into the
books themselves because that media
means a lot to me uh and yeah Twitter
Instagram and all those things for uh
trying to communicate uh my love of the
world and philosophizing thusly um so
just my name
c-o-y-j-a-n-d-r-e-a-u and I love being
here because we can wax poetic about
truly incredible movies and Rotten
Tomatoes is a great platform to love on
movies so uh both of these being fresh
means more people will see them and
movies getting a little bit of extra
boost it's always good the box office is
not a coincidence these movies are great
and support your movie theater see it in
cinemas I want these things to stay open
I love them much well I think it's it's
going to have lung like the president of
Warner Brothers said it's gonna have
long long legs these two films so clever
um thank you all for barvinheimering
with us it was a true true Joy I'm like
schwitzing over here I've been drinking
way too much coffee of like every time
you talk I'm like yeah even though
barberheimer happened because like the
the thing because of the pandemic I love
that Nolan left WB because of the timing
and then releasing day and date and then
them picking the Nolan date for Barbie
and then it turning into Barb and Heimer
because the date no one wasn't gonna
move from turned into the Barbie date
and then they both benefited from it and
it turned into a celebration of Cinema
darn it even that is metamodernistic
that the reaction to the thing became a
meme itself and that reflects both of
these movies commentary on the times I
know it's insane all right big thing
thank you again always happy to be here
that was great it was so much fun thank
you so much for joining us on this very
special double feature episode of the
after show we will see you on the next
one bye
thank you